في هذا المبنى المتهالك في احد ازقه مخيم
شاتيلا للاجئين الفلسطينيين قرب بيروت كان
يسكن بشار عبد السعود
لم تتوقع عائلته عندما اعتقل في اغسطس
الماضي ان تصلها اخبار صادمه عن وفاته
قرار اتهام الصادر عن محكمه العسكريه كان
واضحا في اشاره لان الموقف السوري توفي
جراء التعذيب على ايدي عناصر في جهاز امن
الدوله
وخدوها واشتغلوا ساعتين انا طالب بالعداله
اريد مثل ما صار بزلم بصير بيهم
شنو ذنبه هالساعتين شنو ذنبي شنو ذنب
اطفال هاي ساعتين باكر بادهم مستقبل يا
قدام
[موسيقى]
الدوله اعتبر في لبنان بمثابه تطور قضائي
لافت ذلك ان المنظمات الحقوقيه الدوليه
لطالما انتقلت لبنان جراء ما تصفه باخفاق
سلطاته في التعامل مع اساليب التحقيق التي
تعتمدها الاجهزه الامنيه مع الموقوفين في
المقابل تعتبر السلطات القضائيه اللبنانيه
ان قرار الاتهام بحق عناصر جهاز امن
الدوله يؤكد التزام لبنان بالقوانين التي
تجري التعذيب قرار اليوم
الا المعاهده الدوليه
بالمنظمات الحقوقيه المحليه والدوليه
بالقرار القضائي فانها اعتبر بمثابه مدخل
للمطالبه بحصر عمل المحكمه العسكريه ونقل
كل القضايا المماثله الى المحاكم المدنيه
انفاذا للقانون اللبناني
في لبنان الى نقل هذه القضيه من المحاكم
العسكريه التي لا تتلائم مع معايير
المحاكمه العادله الى القضاء الجزائري
العادي بما يتمشى مع القانون اللبناني
نفسه
والمعايير الدوليه همم له حقوق الانسان
يرى ناشطون ان الاجتهادات القانونيه
للقضاه ضروريه في هذه المرحله لتكريس
مصاري عدم افلاك مرتكب التعذيب من العقاب
في قضايا مماثله ياتي قرار الاتهام بتوقيف
عناصر امنيه بتهمه التعذيب بمثابه تطور
قضائي لافد وذلك بعد عشرات الشكوى والتي
تقدمت بها جهات حقوقيه ولم تفلح اي منها
سابقا في توقيف وموسول افراد من الاجهزه
الامنيه امام القضاء الذي تريده المنظمات
الحقوقيه مدنيه لا عسكريا
الجزيره بيروت